[Music]
the leaders of russia and china could
not have been more explicit about their
relationship when they last met three
weeks before the conflict began
vladimir putin and xi jinping declared
it was a friendship with no limits one
expert says that means china will stand
by russia well i don't think china is
sitting on the fence china is supporting
russia basically it tries to be
diplomatic but uh
giving the gravity of the circumstances
i think being neutral means
means a form of support
she and putin have met 38 times as
national leaders it's not known if she
was made aware of putin's plans for
ukraine at their last get-together
but there's clarity on one issue their
shared aim to create an alternative to
the current world order
china has cast itself as a neutral
player in the conflict abstaining from a
united nations vote condemning russia's
invasion yet is in a unique position to
mediate absolutely i hope so and i
believe so why because china has good
relations with russia on the one hand
and with ukraine on the other hand and
china does not have a stake
involved in this military operation
and china is objective and as china is
also neutral china's foreign minister
insists his country respects the
sovereignty of all nations including
ukraine but the legitimate security
concerns of all countries must also be
respected including russia's my
assessment is that it will most likely
continue this diplomatic dance sort of
saying that sovereignty is important but
at the same time de facto
supporting russia providing economic
assistance to russia
this is a complicated crisis for china
despite its close partnership with
russia its economic future depends in
large part on good trade relations with
europe a europe that's now united behind
tough economic sanctions on russia and
there's an added twist last year china
was ukraine's number one trading partner
[Music]
in recent war games chinese and russian
troops simulated an attack on a nameless
enemy
in ukraine though china insists it's not
taking sides a stance that analysts
argue might be harder to maintain
the longer the conflict goes on
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong